skyline is dotted with aging concrete
blocks similar to grenfell Tower
Lamia and her mum live in a building
close enough to have felt the heat from
the fire there on the 20th floor and are
now worried about their own safety on my
floor there isn't fyrst English's on the
floor below me there isn't I'm assuming
there aren't any fire extinguishers you
know it gives you a sense of panic for
it you're just like I mean I think it's
leaving people a bit paranoid like when
is it going to happen now the public
inquiry into the fire announced by the
Prime Minister will need to establish
why it spread so quickly and whether the
safety regulations are now dangerously
out of date the concrete blocks built in
the 60s and 70s are a world away from
the plush high-rises of the city but in
fact the fire regulations have moved on
very little although nowadays there are
rules on the kind of materials that can
be used the actual safety equipment has
changed very little charred loss can
still be built with just one stairwell a
single escape route from a fire and
there's still no requirement for water
sprinklers even though they slow the
spread of flames they used to be under
the London building acts the requirement
was called section 20 that if you're
building was over a certain height or
sudden size then it had to had to as a
matter of fact has law have sprinklers
but that got removed the new regulations
after the lack no house fire in South
London in 2009 there were calls for
tighter regulations six people died once
the fire authorities inspected
residential blocks not anymore
I think fire service should should
statutorily be consulted every time a
building goes up and have a statutory
consultation we do know that it's very
destruction airy weather people building
putting buildings up Architects and
buildings and controls approved
inspectors always consulted by Brigade
they don't always do it
skyscrapers can be built to protect
those inside the torch building in Dubai
went up in flames two years ago again
cladding the problem but the
construction and safety equipment inside
were faultless the word
no casualties serious questions will now
be asked whether Britain's fire
regulations are good enough Thomas More
Sky News